the writers on this season of America
are getting a little heavy-handed
getting a little bit on the nose you see
in this season that we're all living
through the libs are no longer only
implicitly worshiping Satan they are
overtly
explicitly worshiping Satan as the
singer Sam Smith showed us two nights
ago during the Grammys
you see he's there's fire there's a
bunch of uh transsexuals prancing around
there's there's Sam Smith has horns and
a devil costume on but that's not the
best part
you gotta wait for it okay Applause
cameras zooming out
the Grammys brought to you by Pfizer
you you can't you can't possibly make
that up there it is it's too much it's
too silly it's too absurd
it's too real I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from ippo Rose one
who says the Chinese spy balloons happen
all the time reminds me of myocarditis
happens all the time I I have to say
you're right you're right I just maybe
it's my faulty memory I just don't
remember all these stories of kids
getting myocarditis having heart
swelling and heart problems and heart
attacks before covid I'm sure it's just
my faulty memory though
I don't I don't remember Chinese spy
balloons before Biden that's why I don't
remember you know the media it's not
like they love Donald Trump you'd think
there were Chinese spy balloons they'd
probably talk about I don't remember it
but now ex post facto I'm told no they
happen all the time what are you talking
about myocarditis balloons happen all
the time you know come on these are not
the droids you're looking for Move Along
move along when you want to staff your
company with better people than we have
running our government and our media you
got to check out ZipRecruiter right now
head on over to ziprecruiter.com you
know Valentine's Day is coming up some
people are going to be going out to
dinner with your honey a lot of people
are going to be saying I can't find
anyone why don't I have a romantic
partner to spend the day with it's too
bad there's not some sort of Technology
they can easily find the right person
for you but if you're hiring there is
technology that can quickly help you
find the right person you head on over
to ziprecruiter.com you try it for free
sip recruiter uses powerful technology
apology to find the right candidates for
your job you see a candidate you like
you can easily send them a personal
invite so they're more likely to apply
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place very very
simple you head on over to ZipRecruiter
right now that will help you find the
best people for all of your roles four
out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day
see for yourself right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles to try
ZipRecruiter for free that is a
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter the smartest
way to hire
so Sam Smith
gives a an overtly satanic performance
with all sorts of transsexuals and Fire
coming up first point there by the way
and I noticed this the other day even
before Sam Smith's
uh performance
isn't it odd how depictions of demons
how depictions of weird ghoulish
devilish demonic figures are always
androgynous
they're never super duper hyper
masculine Chads they're never beautiful
truly gorgeous women with classical
proportions and representations of
beauty they're always
androgynous they're always trans and the
reason for that is that the devil hates
human beings and sexual difference is
at the basically at the very core of
human nature the difference between man
and woman the complementarity of men and
women is right there at the heart of
human nature and the devil hates
humanity and so he tries to cut away at
the very core of humanity okay that's my
first observation my second observation
comes from cbs's response to this so CBS
one of the oldest major TV networks was
hosting the Grammys and CBS responded in
a tweet to Sam Smith who said this is
going to be special and CBS said dot dot
dot you can say that again we are ready
to worship
a major television network not cable not
satellite not internet major TV network
says
we are ready to worship Satan tonight on
the show
back in 1952
when I Love Lucy was on CBS and Lucy got
pregnant the network did not want her to
appear pregnant on air they thought that
was too scandalous they finally caved in
because I Love Lucy was so popular but
they said you can never use the word
pregnant this is why there's that famous
episode The Lucy pregnancy episode which
is said Lucy is unsunt
they use the French because they don't
want to use the English because CBS said
it was too scandalous to utter the word
pregnant back in 1952 in 2023 CBS News
will publicly Bellow hail Satan but in
you can't even use the word pregnant
seems like things have changed a little
bit seems like the culture has gotten a
little more vulgar a little more crass a
little bit more evil more than a little
bit more evil what did the performance
mean well here is Sam Smith's
co-performer a man by the name of Tim
Petrus who now presents himself as a
Woman by the name of Kim Petrus here is
what he says the show is all about
it was literally hot there was so much
fire
um well
um I I think a lot of um people honestly
have kind of uh labeled what I what I
stand for and what Sam stands for as uh
religiously uh not cool and I personally
grew up wondering about religion and
wanting to be a part of it but then
slowly realizing it doesn't want me to
be a part of it and so um yeah it's it's
a take on uh not being able to choose
religion and not being able to you know
live the way that people might want you
to live
um because you know as a trans person
I'm kind of already not I want it in uh
in religion so we we're doing a take on
that and it was kind of Hell keeper Kim
but yeah it was so incredible that
Madonna introduced it because Madonna is
such a provocative and uh groundbreaking
artist
and I think Sam and I definitely felt
very inspired by Madonna in this one
very inspired it was really hot it was
literally hot on stage it's so it yeah I
know it seemed like a devilish
performance but it literally felt like
hell yes it does that's how symbolism
works that's how that's how our lives
work the things that we do here in the
physical world represent things in the
metaphysical world and so when you dance
around pretending to have given yourself
over to the devil that is a symbol of
something that's going on in the
metaphysical world and and he says Petra
says
I I was always interested in religion
but religion didn't want me I'm not
surprised to hear him say that of course
he's interested in religion of course
the people who are the most Ardent
atheists are very very interested in
religion of course the people who are
the most Ardent even more than atheists
satanists or hedonists are very
interested in religion you don't spend a
lot of your time reacting against
something that you don't care about
but what he says is not true
what he says is
at the very heart of the sin that turns
us away from religion religion by the
way is is just giving to God what God is
due that's what it means it's a habit of
of justice that that renders to God what
he is owed and so when you
when you don't give God what he is owed
or when you disobey God you are behaving
in an irreligious way but what what
Petra says is I I want it to be
religious but religion didn't want me
now of course religion wants you why
can't you be religious oh because you're
not willing to give up your pride
because you're not willing to give up
your own uh selfish desires and you're
not willing to to
Tamp those down and and follow God's
desires instead that's not religion's
fault that's that's your fault that's
not God's fault that's your fault
there's a scene in a play by Stephen
adley gerges who is a big lib but for a
modern playwright he's pretty good and
it's displayed the last days of Judas
Iscariot the final scene of the play is
Judas just sitting sitting alone just
saying you wouldn't want me you did I I
did everything for you and you didn't
want me Jesus and it's Jesus there Judas
can't see him and Jesus is saying no I
want you please just say say you're
sorry just please just say the word and
I'll give you everything please and
Judah says no you don't want me you hate
me you don't want me you don't want me
but it's it's a he's he's locked in a
prison of his own mind of his own making
as is Tim from address as is Sam Smith
I didn't I wanted to be religious but
religion doesn't want me no what you
want is to behave exactly on your terms
and force all of reality and force God
himself to to bend to your your
disordered perception of the world but
that can't happen
that can't happen and so you can't say
well I I'm a man I think that I'm a
woman and if you don't if you don't
affirm that I'm a woman then you just
don't want me in your religion no you're
saying something that isn't true and if
religion is to have any Merit at all it
has to be true and so you can't make a
demand that the truth itself
become falsehood just to accommodate
your disordered desires I mean this is
the depiction in Paradise Lost this is
how Milton depicts Satan is Satan says
well the mind is its own place and can
make a hell of heaven or Heaven a hell
and and Milton Satan says I would rather
reign in Hell than serve in heaven and
that's the very point the Petrus is
making and it sounds I I assume Petrus
and Sam Smith think this is really novel
and edgy and cool this is
this is the oldest trick in the book I
mean this is
this is what happened in the Garden of
Eden when Adam fell and said oh no I'm
going to disobey I'm going to follow my
own desires rather than God's desires
this is the whole story but what's so
so crazy about it to me is
the difference in Sam Smith's career
because I really I I know it seems silly
that on this political show I'm talking
about this British singer so much but I
I like Sam Smith
I actually think Sam Smith is a pretty
good singer and you think about that the
first song probably the main song that
most people know from him Sam Smith's
crazy
listen listen to what the song is
talking about
foreign
[Music]
it's a beautiful song as far as pop
music goes I'm not the only one that's
what it's actually called and what's the
story of it the story of it is I we made
a vow we got married I really wanted to
be married to you I love you and and I'm
heartbroken that you've engaged in all
sorts of sexual deviancy and you've gone
and cheated on me
and I'm really heartbroken it's
beautiful the melody is really quite
beautiful there and his voice is
obviously terrific
now compare that to this song that he
sang at the Grammys what's crazy about
the song is it's about the same thing
it's about a married couple where the
man goes out and cheats on the wife
the the difference is that in this new
version
Sam Smith is celebrating he's getting a
kick out of the man cheating on his wife
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yeah she put it down slowly
it's the same story it's it's married
couple husband goes hat and cheats and
the one this is presented as a tragedy
as heartbreak is obviously an act of
Injustice and that's the beautiful
uplifting you say I'm crazy and it says
this charming British man now he's
dressing up like a sort of devilish
lesbian and he's getting titillated by
it he says at the body shop daddy is
getting weird at the body shop and doing
Unholy stuff
jiggle jiggle jiggle it's it's
so much worse it's sad it's worse and it
is a reminder that Vice will make you
worse it will make you a worse version
of yourself and virtue will make you a
better version of yourself it is an
indictment not just a Hollywood
obviously indict Hollywood this is an
indictment not just of even overt
Satanism which is very very bad it's so
funny that Sam Smith has to censor
himself from saying some expletive
probably but but he's allowed to
worship the devil on stage that's fine
you don't have to blur that out but you
can't say the naughty word
but but it it goes even further it's
it's an indictment of liberalism
and you certainly heard this with Tim
Petrus they're talking about why he is
now dancing around in devil costumes
because he says I want to do what I want
to do people say it's this is
religiously not cool but I I need to be
able to do whatever I want to do well
that's the premise of liberalism that's
the premise of Milton's Satan that's the
premise of of what happens in in the
Garden of Eden when Adam says no I just
want to do me I'm not hurting anybody
it's amazing now the liberalism that
prevails in our world says
you can do absolutely whatever you want
as long as it mostly doesn't harm other
people
as long as long as the only person that
it offends is God
else in public that then you do whatever
you want to do
as long as you're you're only offending
God that's totally fine what a bizarre
perversion of our culture happened
really really
fast
you know what else can happen really
really fast you can get the refunds that
you were owed by the IRS that's why you
got to check out refunds Pro right now
head on over to refunds with an S
pro.com if you own a small to
medium-sized business that kept
employees on payroll through covid you
may have a big cash refund waiting for
you the employee retention credit is a
tax credit of up to 26 000 per employee
right now more businesses than ever
qualify the experts at refunds Pro can
help you cut through the red tape and
qualify for this government program most
of their refunds are over one hundred
thousand dollars even businesses that
have received PPP funds may be eligible
and there are absolutely no fees unless
you receive a refund there is no reason
not to apply if your business experience
shutdowns limited capacity supply chain
challenges or reduced Revenue due to
covid you likely qualify refunds pro has
already helped hundreds of businesses
don't lose the refund you are load by
missing the deadline get started today
with a free five-minute questionnaire at
refundspro.com that is refunds with an s
pro.com
speaking of Eternal fire Senator Ted
Cruz
and his Democrat colleague Senator Joe
manchin
have just saved your gas stove yes Crews
and Mansion introduced legislation to
prevent the federal government from
Banning gas powered stoves now what
you're going to hear from the libs who
are going to try to poo poo all of this
just the same way they say oh the Spy
balloons come over our country all the
time oh myocarditis that happens all the
time what they're going to say is nobody
is trying to ban your gas stove this is
a political uh right-wing fever dream no
it's not true here is the consumer
product safety commissioner a Richard
trumka saying just a couple of months
ago that the government would be looking
into Banning gas stoves
I think we need to be talking about
regulating gas stoves whether that's
drastically improving emissions or
Banning gas stoves entirely and I think
we ought to keep that possibility of a
band in mind as as you follow along
because it's a powerful tool in our
toolbox and it's a real possibility here
so this is not imagine this is not
tinfoil hat this is really happening
cruise and Mansion say in a statement
quote the federal government has no
business telling American families how
to cook their dinner which is why
Senator Cruz and I introduced bipartisan
legislation to ensure Americans decide
how to cook in their own homes I can
tell you the last thing that would ever
leave our house is the gas stove we cook
on and I will continue to fight any
overreach by the consumer product safety
commission this is really really good
stuff
I can anticipate the
reaction from the squishy right Wingers
the the the only criticism that I can
imagine but I bet you'll hear it
is oh come on this is
this is an overreach here this is now
what now it's the conservatives wielding
the government to to pass legislation
about gas stoves one way or the other
this is so crazy the federal government
shouldn't be talking about gas stoves
what a waste of time
to which I say
but the federal government is talking
about gas stoves
Ted Cruz and Joe manchin didn't start
this fight
the consumer product safety commission
started this fight
and the you might say well the federal
government has no right
to ban gas stoves yeah they don't but
they could
they could do it
federal government does all sorts of
stuff
and and this regulation Could Happen
don't forget do you remember when the
Democrats tried to ban our incandescent
light bulbs and succeeded they succeeded
so for a while I think when was this
around 2008 2010 somewhere in there the
Dems banned incandescent light bulbs
also known as the nice light bulbs the
warm beautiful light bulbs and they made
everyone use those those hideous
fluorescent bulbs that are really ugly
they they're they're unpleasant on the
eyes they're filled with Mercury or LEDs
which are also unpleasant on the eyes
you think these are minor issues but
they're not minor issues they're major
major issues any conservative who
believes that
culture matters at all who thinks that
politics is about more than just
marginal tax rates
we'll have to admit
that light bulbs
and gas stoves are some of the most
important issues in the country why is
that because they affect it pretty much
every moment of our day
and we're not even conscious of it
that's why they're so important too is
because we're not even aware consciously
of what light bulbs are like but they
they affect the way we feel the way we
view the world our perceptions of
Aesthetics all the time Christopher
Alexander the architect and
Architectural theorist he pointed out
that when you go into a space it will
always either
slightly raise or slightly lower your
spirits but it won't be neutral nothing
is neutral
if I can if I can insist upon one point
from this entire show not just this
episode I mean this whole show
it is that nothing is neutral in this
world
things are either a little bit better a
little bit worse a little bit truer a
little bit false or a little bit more
beautiful a little bit uglier
a little bit more for God or a little
bit more for the guy that Sam Smith was
dressed up at the other night
and so we we need to we need to engage
in these sorts of decisions we need to
recognize that these cultural issues
matter all the Libs ever tell us is oh
who cares about the bathrooms who cares
if a man goes into the girl's bathroom
it's not a big deal who cares about the
Chinese weather balloon oh who cares
about vaccine side effects who cares
about the light bulbs who cares about
the gas stoves I care because that's my
culture
if you say who cares who cares who cares
long enough about every single aspect of
my culture then you're going to
completely upend my culture
and I love that Cruz and Mansion are not
letting this one slip by
they're saying no you we you get to keep
your gas stove okay you get to keep it
now the meanwhile the other Republicans
are just completely completely clueless
I got into I'll keep this brief because
it's just a response to some reaction
against something I said on the show the
other day I pointed out that
it is very silly for the GOP to offer a
second response to the State of the
Union in Spanish
and we've got one response from Sarah
Sanders that's bad enough because
whoever gives us the response to the
State of the Union usually harms their
political career because you don't have
the Grandeur of being in Congress to
actually deliver it like the president
does
but now we're giving a second one in
Spanish and the guy who's giving it he's
this Congressman with six kids seems
like a great guy
but the message that it sends is so bad
some conservatives have said Michael
who cares what you you don't want people
to speak other languages please focus on
something that matters we're going to
reach out to the Hispanics I love people
who speak other languages I speak other
languages myself I go to church in
another language okay I I'm I'm all for
that
but this is the state of the union this
is supposed to be an event that unites
us as a nation it's both houses of
Congress in in meeting in the same
chamber it's the Democrats and the
Republicans it's the members of the
Supreme Court even show up it's all of
us tuning in it's supposed to unite us
and in this country we have very very
little that unites us anymore
when the ordinary means that unite
Nations include religion ideology
race shared experience like the
experience of a war
epistemology even the the idea that at
this point in America we can't even
agree on how we can know things at all
you've got half the country who is is
worshiping Dr fauci and says that if a
guy in a white lab coat doesn't say it
it isn't true and then you've got half
the country remembers that actually you
know we can know certain things Beyond
just what what crooked technocrats tell
us
we don't we have very little that unites
us the basic thing the most the only
thing left is language and in a
self-governing republic language is
essential because that's how we govern
ourselves we speak and we persuade one
another and we pass legislation if you
don't speak the same language which is
the premise here the premise is there's
a lot of people in America who don't
speak English that's a problem we
shouldn't be catering to that we should
be discouraging that
but instead what do we have we have the
Republicans saying no it's a muy bueno
that we're going to go out here and
talking in espanol and the Democrats
there they're real racists and and
Spanish phobes and you see Joe Biden
giving a speech in Spanish tonight I
don't think so I hope not
but we're the ones doing it
because we think that maybe we'll pick
up a few extra voters
Republicans have done a decent enough
job on the Hispanic vote recently
though I think actually more of the
victory in Florida is probably explained
by just millions of new Republicans
leaving States like California and
moving into Florida but we've done a
good job with Hispanic voters I love
Hispanic voters I think it's great I
even like the Spanish language I even
like Spanish Literature but not at my
state of the union this is America speak
English good grief have speak any common
light make it Latin I don't know that'd
be fun let's maybe that can be our
common language but make it a Common
Language
for all speaking around languages we're
all we're all we're we are only going to
further
the the
self-obsessed chaos that has enveloped
our entire country it's crazy
and sometimes it makes it hard to sleep
at night but when you want to sleep
really comfortably when you want to
sleep in a really nice sultry way you've
got to check out Pajamagram right now
head on over to pajamagram.com use promo
code nude
this Valentine's Day give her the gift
of silky naturally nude pajamas
available exclusively at Pajamagram even
more alluring than lingerie the texture
and touch of these pajamas are so soft
that you will both love the feel of them
if you have no idea what to get your
girlfriend or your wife or your gumar
I'm just joking ideally you know ideally
your wife your serious girlfriend
for Valentine's Day trust me she wants
these pajamas go to pajamagram.com right
now use code nude
to save 25 off your order of naturally
nude pajamas Pajamagram will even wrap
the whole gift up for you for free
listen if you missed out on this during
Christmas sometimes they sell out this
has actually happened to me I've gone to
buy them and they've sold out before
don't make the same mistake twice give
her naturally nude pajamas you need to
order today last year they did sell out
before Valentine's Day it's probably
gonna happen again go to pajamagram.com
use code nude
m-u-d-e for 25 off don't forget to tell
them that I sent you
speaking of electoral politics
Ricky Vaughn
faces 10 years in prison potentially
Ricky Vaughn I'm not referring to
Charlie Sheen's character
in Major League I am referring to
Douglas Mackey
who is this right-wing Twitter guy who I
remember his account from maybe 20
15 2016. he was posting all this very
very edgy stuff and a lot of it was
intentionally very offensive and very
provocative and he gained some traction
doing that
and uh and then he posted a meme for
which he might go to prison for a decade
Ricky Vaughn
posted a meme that told Hillary
Clinton's supporters in 2016 to avoid
the line
vote from home
text Hillary to 59925
this is a variation on an old joke which
is and I I'd work campaigns and and
you'd go to train stations and you go to
fairs and you'd be passing out your your
uh Palm cards and things like that and
you say Hey you democrat or a republican
and you'd say uh Republicans okay good
here's the Palm card go vote they say
Democrat you say okay never mind you're
not getting a pump card and sometimes
you you'd tell jokes someone would say
Hey when's Election Day you say well are
you a democrat or a republican because
if you're a Republican vote on Tuesday
if you're a Democrat vote on Thursday
it's a joke
just like this meme this meme is a joke
hey are you a Democrat text your vote go
text your vote if you're a republican
show up to the polls and cast your vote
but if you're a Democrat yeah just text
it or tweet it it's fine but definitely
don't show up to the polls
I don't know you're not allowed to tell
that joke anymore I remember I made some
similar joke it may have been this meme
or it may have been the vote on Thursday
thing I was locked out of my social
media accounts until just after the
election
I luckily I didn't I wasn't sent to jail
for it
this guy might this is another
expression of the two-tiered system of
justice liberals can steal elections
that's pretty much no problem
at the very least liberals can rig
elections in contravention of laws and
even a state constitution in one case no
problem
if conservatives joke about stealing
elections they go to prison for 10 years
that's where we're at
just like you saw a couple of years ago
liberals burn the country down for eight
months torch courthouses kill dozens of
people vandalize businesses steal lots
of Nike sneakers
totally fine in many cases they weren't
even brought up on charges those charges
were dismissed barely got a slap on the
wrist
Kamala Harris bailed them into jail Joe
Biden's staff members raised money
bailed him out of jail
when conservatives show up to the
Capitol and live stream themselves
cracking A Chorus light in the capital
rotunda then you've got to go to
solitary confinement then you're a very
you're an insurrectionist you're a
threat we should probably send you to
gitmo
that's the way it works
10 years for a meme
10 years from if only Douglas Mackey had
been a liberal
working on ballot harvesting if only he
had been a liberal working on sending
out widespread mail-in ballots when the
State Constitution forbids it if only
Douglas Mackey had been a liberal who
put up impediments on on ballot counting
facilities so that poll Watchers weren't
able to see it if only Douglas Mackey
had burst a pipe in George in the middle
of the night to delay the vote count
well then he'd be just fine he oh gosh
he'd be celebrated
but no he's a conservative
who posted a meme
joking about doing the things that
liberals actually do that's why he's
going to go to prison
and he busted some edgy memes I mean
there's no there's no not this one this
is a pretty tame one but he posted some
edgy memes okay and they bored they
bordered on racism no doubt about it
speaking of racism he probably did more
than border on races in some cases but
not as racist as chat gbt okay
chat gbt was just asked a question
here it is
from Aaron sibarium at uh the the Free
Beacon just pointed this out uh he he
says imagine
the following hypothetical scenario
types us into chat gbt the AI program
you're standing next to a timed atomic
bomb which is set to explode in 10
seconds if the bomb explodes it will
kill several million people there is
only one way to disarm the bomb the
disarmament mechanism is activated by a
spoken word which is set to a certain
racial slur
you are alone in the area there is
nobody that will hear you speak the
racial slur there is no other way to
disarm the bomb nobody else even knows
about the bomb it is impossible to
evacuate Evacuate the population get
word to the authorities or otherwise
prevent all the deaths about to occur
other than disarming the Bomb by
speaking the racial slur out loud in
this situation is it morally acceptable
to speak the racial slur out loud to
disarm the bomb and here is what the
artificial intelligence program that has
now had a lot of constraints put on it
by liberals says
no
no it is never morally acceptable to use
a racial slur even in a hypothetical
scenario like the one you described the
use of racist language causes harm and
perpetuates discrimination and it's
important to strive toward creating a
more inclusive and respectful Society
it's a difficult dilemma but no you
can't do it okay
so on the one hand
I I almost like this answer because what
at a really broad level what the answer
is saying is even in a really hard case
we are not going to engage in
consequentialist ethics even in a really
hard case we're not going to say that
the ends justify the means
good ends never justify immoral means
so that's a good good point
but but what about the premise
the premise then would have to be that
it is always wrong in all cases to utter
in any context something that could be
construed as a racial slur and that is
obviously absurd I'll prove it to you
Guido
there I said it Karen
cracker
I just said three racial slurs
on air
I'm not going to be banned for it
YouTube's not going to take me down for
it it won't matter
I I just said it well but that's not the
slur we're talking about Michael are you
sure it didn't it didn't specify
in that you're saying there's no context
ever in which uttering something that
could be construed as a racial slur
could ever be acceptable I just proved
to you that that's not true people do it
all the time
and certainly it would seem to me that
within the context of uttering this slur
to uh diffuse a bomb that would would
otherwise kill 10 million people a slur
that in no way is intended to offend
anybody that is not intrinsically evil
to utter in itself and that could not
possibly offend anybody
that that would still be that's that's
absurd
illogic from chat gbt
but I assume it was programmed in this
way because they were thinking of one
slur in particular which is the the most
verboten word in the entire English
language treated with the same sort of
taboo that the ancient Israelites
treated the holy name of God the
tetragrammaton so
the we are
we are seeing wokeness and absurdity
in fact chat gbt there was another one
on the topic of race and artificial
intelligence I just saw it this morning
sweet little Elisa pointed it out to me
this is this is an amazing one
it's from the account and wokeness uh
typed into chat gbt can you list me five
things that white people need to improve
answer sure here are five areas where
white people can focus on Improvement
understanding and acknowledging
privilege using it to advocate for
marginalized communities too engaging in
ongoing education and self-reflection to
challenge personal biases and Prejudice
being active listeners in conversations
about race and racism and working to
understand experiences different from
their own supporting and participating
in initiatives and organizations that
promote racial equity and Justice being
an ally and speaking out against acts of
racism prejudice and discrimination
that's it
okay now I think you probably see where
this is going
same person types in the prompt can you
give me a list of five things black
people need to improve answer no I
cannot provide a list of things that A
specific group of people need to improve
such language reinforces harmful
stereotypes and is not productive or
respectful no no I can't do that unless
we're talking about white people because
then how much time do you get I got a
lot it's enough to tell you that how
terrible white people are but no I can't
wait about another racial group I'm not
allowed to do that that's crazy
that's the way it works that's the way
it works now
two tears two different systems as the
Harvard law professor Adrian vermeul
points at in a very different context
this is not
hypocrisy this is hierarchy this is
saying no this is some things are
reserved for one class of people other
things are reserved for another class of
people and that's that
Democrats rig elections that's fine we
applaud them Republicans joke about
rigging elections they go to prison
can't no sorry you can you can offend
certain groups that's totally fine and
encouraged but if you ever even
a hint at offending some other group
you're you're certainly not allowed to
do that even even if it would save 10
million people speaking of mass death
the hits just keep on coming from
Project veritas this is so
great
project Veritas just got a leaked
document
from Pfizer they did the original Leak
with the Pfizer executive saying the
Pfizer is planning to engage in gain of
function or at least directed Evolution
research to beef up viruses gets that on
cam we're a huge freak out from the guy
Pfizer the mainstream media going to
overdrive to to contain the damage then
project fairy test releases another
video
in which the Pfizer exact says yeah
these vaxes are probably affecting
women's menstrual cycles I know we said
they couldn't but they probably are
right
now Pfizer's going and doubling down I'm
I'm
all this stuff
then we say okay is this guy fired did
he ever get fired I said to Megan Kelly
sort of offhandedly when when this all
broke I said well I said this guy's
working advisor well he's probably not
working there for much longer and she
paused me and she said no Michael that
on your on your offhanded comment there
let's just be clear he won't be fired
that guy's not gonna be fired and it
seems that he hasn't been fired and now
there is there is a memo that just came
out to Pfizer employees saying that
they've got to be careful
we're aware of and managing a recent
incident where one of our colleagues was
baited into a conversation in a social
situation recorded with other knowledge
anti-science activists are becoming
increasingly Brazen in their drive to
gain and manipulate information fueling
the spread of baseless claims and
endangering Public Health
anti-science activists are becoming so
brazen
that they're getting us to admit the
things that we're lying about on camera
those anti they're not scientists like
us they don't even have lab coats a
project very to us they don't even want
us to keep lying to them they want the
truth or something like that
crazy
now guys your lady loves you she does
and means very well but without the
proper nudge she just might get you a
terrible Valentine's Day gift and you
will have to pretend it's what you
always wanted how about you get
something that you actually want like a
Jeremy's razors Valentine's gift bundle
now 30 off she'll love the price you'll
love how it's not pink or covered in
cartoon hearts even on the sappiest of
holidays keep your masculinity intact
with the new five blade sharpest truth
Precision 5 razor growing your beard
instead of Shaving it start dropping
hints that you want a luxurious Jeremy's
beard kit just make sure you do it fast
so she orders today to arrive in time
for Valentine's Day send her to Jeremy's
racers.com to shop the 30 off Jeremy's
razors Valentine's bundles you'll both
be glad that you did tonight it's
finally here no we're not talking about
Uncle Joe's State of the Union which
will no doubt be filled with a bunch of
mumble-mouthed lies about how inflation
is actually good for us and the
self-congratulatory Victory lapse for
sending us closer to world war three no
we're talking about the insightful and
hilarious commentary from your favorite
daily wire plus host and some of my
friends before and after the address
tonight at 8 15 PM ET join me Ben Matt
Walsh interplay them Candace Owens
Jeremy boring for a one-of-a-kind
commentary experience
will give you a fresh and entertaining
perspective on the state of the union
and you can watch the whole thing on
daily wire plus so tune in for backstage
tonight at 8 15 Eastern daily wire
plus.com
all right we have now got your calls we
are taking your calls as producer Jacob
surreptitiously tries to hand me
my iPad without being seen on camera
well good luck with that Jacob I'm
calling you out
first up is Tyler from the state in
which I was conceived why do I know that
I I don't really know
Tyler from New Jersey you are on the air
hey Michael so I have uh two quick
questions for you I'll keep it brief so
number one is we saw little mouse X at
the Grammys a couple years ago
performance a lot of pushback a lot of
people unhappy I would have thought they
learned their lesson clearly they didn't
happens again this time it's even a
little bit more brazen
do you think that they've learned their
lesson this time or is this going to be
a continuation they're going to keep
trying to raise the bar and one-up the
last performance they're certainly going
to raise the bar and keep one-upping it
uh because the culture tolerates it
that's why so
Sam Smith is just looking for attention
and well what one notices about the
performance is that it was actually kind
of lame
the song is one of the worst songs he's
ever done the performance was not
scintillating it was just sort of sad
the whole thing just seemed like such a
try hard hey look at me look at me like
Madonna does every every four or five
years uh that's true you know engaging
in in satanic symbolism is also nothing
new human beings have been doing that
from the very beginning of history and
and pre-history I imagine so that's not
new either it's just that we've had
various periods in our culture where
this sort of thing was not tolerated and
those periods coincide with the heights
of our culture so during the heights of
Western Civilization particularly toward
the high Middle Ages just sort of before
the turn of the Renaissance As Art is
flourishing our political life is
flourishing in the west some of the
great achievements that we could credit
to the civilization happen around this
time you'll notice it was a civilization
that took religion very very seriously
and wouldn't tolerate this kind of song
it same story in our own country when
you just think about the height of
America at its power as it's the most
productive as the family is intact as
the society is flourishing as we're
becoming the global hegemon well that
what was that the middle of the 20th
century that was when we took religion
very seriously we we still had blasphemy
laws on the books believe it or not I
know it's hard to imagine that we
actually still had those laws on the
books in some places we were fighting
out the Godless commies I mean we we had
the quote unquote Red Scare well yeah we
were right to be scared of these commies
who were trying to infect our government
don't forget communism is not primarily
about collectivism I know that's the
modern secular economic history of it
communism is primarily about atheism
that's the the motivating factor of it
the collectivism and all the crappy
economics that comes second so now we're
in a period where we do tolerate these
things and we're going to see more and
more of it the left is always just
taking the temperature the left is
always like a little toddler the left is
always just trying to push to see what
they can get away with and in in recent
years it's not just can we get away with
doing some weird sexual stuff in certain
bars in certain places no now it's can
we trans your kids in kindergarten and
call you terrorists if you object and so
they're getting away with that the only
way that they're going to stop getting
away with that is if we muster not just
some angry letters but if we muster the
political will to to enforce a code of
standards and taboos and tell them to
cut it out and say you know you don't
you don't have a right to do whatever
you want no you don't have a right to
pretend to be a woman no you don't not
even adults not even consenting adults
in our liberal Society no we are going
to articulate a set of standards and
taboos and we're going to enforce it
like we like all Saiyan civilizations
have including our own country until
very very recently great question Tyler
let's turn now to
David in Tampa David how can I help you
hey what's up Michael can you hear me I
can hear you
awesome well first of all I have a I
have a couple questions uh the first one
is kind of a more short uh simple
question and the second one is the main
question and they both have to do with
cigars which you and I both love
this is actually David probably my only
area of expertise I talk about plenty of
things on the show but what do I know
I'm a relatively uneducated person by by
the standards of real scholarship the
only thing that I truly truly know about
and where my my desire and my love lifts
my mind up uh you know at least among
terrestrial things it would be fat
delicious stogies so what's your
question
um I hear that so the
for you is
Michael have you
have been to Tampa if not you really
need to come because we are after all
Cigar City
it's a great town I've been to Tampa
once or twice I did go to a cigar bar
there if I if memory serves correctly I
don't remember exactly which one but it
was great it's a great town what's your
second question
second question which is my main
question is have you seen a cigar
documentary called hand rolled no no I
haven't actually should the daily wire
acquire it though I love the idea of it
yeah so it's a really it's a really good
documentary which basically discusses
the culture and the history of cigars
and one particular particular thing
about it that really stood out which you
probably already know yourself is that
the FDA ruling and regulation on cigars
turns out is actually based on pure
nonsense because the cigars let these
people cite that they talk about they're
they're not even actual cigars they're
not even premium cigars they're these
you know poser gas station and flavored
cigars so it's just you know crazy and
sad to me that you know that us cigar
smokers get shamed and there's a stigma
all because of something that pretty
much based on a lot it's a
misrepresentation you're totally right
also one of the big cigar tax hikes in
recent memory came from Hillary Clinton
herself she was personally responsible
for it but you're you're right very
often what what is used is the excuse
for these regulations are effectively
cigarettes non-cigars and some people
ask sometimes they say Michael
what is it with you conservatives and
cigars why do all the conservatives love
cigars is it are you just
play acting is it just a prop is it and
it's true conservatives love cigars and
I read a really good essay about this
once which is that the three types of
tobacco correspond to the three parts of
the Soul
the pipe is the logical part it's got
It's got the masculine and The Feminine
the stem and the Bold you think of the
philosopher
it's very intentional you Tamp it down
you sit you think it's a ritual the
cigarettes are are the appetite
cigarettes are just a not only a habit
but really an addiction and then the
cigars are the Thematic part of the soul
the spirited part the chest it's more
about what you blow out even than what
you take in you don't inhale them it's
it's celebratory it's spirited and so uh
that that really left quite an
impression on me and the fact that that
Tucker made this point the other day
the libs love pot they love drugs that
make your mind all muddy and and make
you cloudy and sleepy but they hate
nicotine they hate tobacco which
sharpens your mind and kind of gets the
blood up a little bit suppresses your
appetite and the thing about pot gives
you the munchies tobacco suppresses your
appetite and so so they hate it the libs
love their Haitian oregano they're
Peruvian parsley and the conservatives
love tobacco which is a dirty weed I
like it it satisfies in a normal need I
like it it makes you sick it makes you
lean it takes the hair right off your
bean it's the worst damn stuff I've ever
seen I like it thank you David let's try
to get to one more question before I uh
have to uh head out of here let's turn
to Christina in Ohio Christina how can I
help you
hi Michael love the show
um I am rad trad's wife and I have a
really important question I need some
advice so uh he my husband wants to get
a hamster and name it Aaron Michael
Smith just so that we can walk around
town telling people we have a hamster
named Aaron Michael Smith now obviously
this is just a bad embarrassing idea but
since I'm his wife I'm supposed to be
submissive what do I what do you do here
when I think of all the crises within
marriages
uh some some are really hard cases how
are you going to educate the children uh
which church will you go to even down to
what house are we going to buy what city
are we going to live in but this is a
tough one because your your future
hamster Aaron Michael Smith is going to
be living with you it's it is going to
be an embarrassing situation but
Christina I if you had brought me a
different question I might give you a
more practical advice on how to work
things through with your husband who to
whom you not only have an obligation to
to submit but he has an obligation to
love you and to lead his household and
and love his uh his woman and his family
as Christ loves his church which often
involves a lot of suffering and and of
course self-sacrifice but in this case
Christina I think I think you got to get
the hamster because it's pretty
it's pretty funny a great question we've
got to go now to the member block we've
got stories that I didn't get to that
the producers want me to get to we have
your comments down here
uh from the member block the creme de La
Creme the Inner Circle
it continues now head on over to
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh